what's going on guys this is rob and i
have a theory which is not really mine
it was actually sent to me by my editor
which he came up with based on a comment
that was left by one of you guys which
is that king the conqueror's plan has
already started and in fact it started
before the events of loki and that we're
gonna see it play out in its totality
leading all the way through phase six
and into the kang dynasty now here's the
thing i know a lot of you guys right off
the bat are gonna say rob that doesn't
make any sense because kane the
conqueror didn't come into existence
until he who remains was killed by
silvie at the end of loki yes and no the
reason why it seems that way is because
you're not taking into account the
cascading effect and this is something
that hasn't really been explained in the
mcu it was explained in jonathan
hickman's fantastic four which we know
the marvel cinematic universe borrows
very very heavily from the work of
jonathan hickman because it's so complex
and it offers so much explanation on the
back end in terms of the significant
things that go on in marvel comics
outside of simply just superhero antics
the way that this was explained and we
can kind of apply it to the events of
loki in order to make it make more sense
that if we look at the explanations that
were given to us because they were all
over the damn place you know that doctor
strange multiverse of madness has in
effect cleared all of that up that what
we have right now and what we got when
it came to the ending of loki is that at
some point along the line the multiverse
came into existence you had all these
different alternate realities and some
of those alternate realities basically
gave us immortus or he who remains
whatever you want to call him but some
of the other realities gave us kang the
conqueror as we know from the loki show
a war broke out between the various
kangs which threatened to destroy the
entirety of the multiverse this led to
he who remains one of the different
versions of himself that came into
existence this led to him basically
weaponizing goliath and then in turn
wiping out all the different alternate
realities across the multiverse that
would have led to king the conqueror
this allowed him to basically create the
sacred timeline and then form the tva to
ensure that any alternate reality that
could come into existence that would
lead to kang would be destroyed and
that's how the multiverse just
functioned for however in the hell long
when sylvie killed he who remains it
allowed the sacred timeline to just
expand unchecked and all these different
alternate realities started spawning
which of course inevitably led to
different variants of kane the conqueror
one of these variants is likely more
powerful than all the others and that's
the variant of kang that we will see in
ant-man quantum mania as well as the
kang dynasty likely the one leading the
show if we end up getting a council of
kang of sorts and so what this means is
that if we take the cascading effect
into account then in effect things
happened in this way that what happened
here is that when immortus when he who
remains died and the multiverse started
spawning out for a time there was simply
just he who remains who was just laying
dead and that was basically it but with
these alternate realities coming into
existence it means now there were all
these different variants of kane coming
into existence as we know kane the
conqueror has the ability to time travel
so likely what happened is one of those
kings the prime king the one we saw in
quantum mania went back in time and
ensured his own victory during the
original kang war basically killing he
who remains or immortus somewhere along
the line this creates a cascading effect
right it's like a meteor hitting the
ocean and creating this tidal wave
except in this instance the meteor is
king the conqueror killing immortus
during the kang war and the tidal wave
being the resulting change across the
entirety of the timeline this is the
reason why when loki got pushed back to
the tva headquarters that there were no
statues of the timekeepers that instead
it was a statue of kang because he was
the one running the show so then the
question has to be asked if that's the
case
then what's this plan that king has
basically set in motion and the answer
to this is that in effect a lot of
things pretty much stayed the same that
one of the things that was established
over the course of the tva is that there
are absolute constants that not even a
mortise can change and by extension
seemingly not even kane can change there
are things that just have to happen
there's no way to undo them there's no
way to stop them there's no way to
prevent it we saw this happen in a few
different instances the what if episode
for that alternate reality version of
doctor strange that kept trying to save
christine palmer that's an example of
that but we also know that there are
some players there that actually had the
ability to defeat king the conqueror so
we say for example that somebody like
tony stark who used the quantum realm to
develop time travel that he in turn now
has the same level of power as king the
conqueror that if tony stark had lived
that he could in turn orchestrate a kind
of multiversal avengers team and then go
back into the past and presumably win
the kang war in some form or fashion and
that would basically lead to a
restoration of the sacred timeline so
what better way to get tony stark out of
the picture than to just let him die
than to not step in than to not do
anything to save the life of tony stark
the idea of captain america going back
into the past living his life with peggy
carter and then basically growing old
that's part of king's plan because now
captain america is out of the picture
that when you look at the fantastic four
which presumably took off in the 1960s
and whether we go with my theory which
is that they're literally just trying to
find a way back but they just keep
ending up in alternate realities they
came to conquer allowed that to happen
he allowed the fantastic four to end up
in the time stream because he knows that
they're gonna get lost there that it
allows them to be removed from the
equation all these things the way that
things have unfolded have actually been
allowed to unfold by kane the conqueror
this is almost evidenced by what we saw
at the end of the loki tv show when you
basically had loki arriving back at the
tva headquarters and you literally had
like morbius immorbius right like owen
wilson's character who was basically
saying no no no right like he wants us
to let the multiverse unfold right he
wants us to let the multiverse spiral
out of control that the actions of kang
isn't so much about stopping a thing
from happening that the idea of kang is
actually letting things happen
specifically if that thing happens to
benefit him which is really really
awesome because it stands in the way of
like everything we've seen thanos was
about stopping the other avengers from
getting the infinity stone so he could
have them for himself the avengers were
trying to stop thanos so they could have
the infinity stones and they could keep
them from blinking out half the life in
the universe it's one of those things
that constantly goes on with the tva out
of the picture or at least a tva under
the control of a cane to conquer it
would make perfect sense that if the tv
becomes aware of the fact that the
fantastic four are out there in the
multiverse the king says no let them
travel because if they're out there
they're not stopping me right they don't
even know that i exist they have no idea
what's going on with me why make them
aware of that if i don't have to that's
kind of what's going on he's operating
in a very very secretive way but a lot
of these things are always happening
right a lot of these things are a result
of king's actions thor losing his
identity no longer being the serious
thor we know and being the comedic thor
that's kang allowing that to take place
instead of stepping in or instead of
orchestrating the timeline in such a way
to where thor doesn't decapitate thanos
or thor does aim for the head and kill
him in infinity war and thor maintains
his serious nature that instead thor
loses himself right the incredible hulk
being pacified all those different
things all of that is a result of kang
that is effectively hands off that he's
actually allowing the timeline to unfold
this way as opposed to making changes to
the timeline because as things stand
right now in the marvel cinematic
universe there's seemingly no one out
there in the earth 616 reality that
could stop kane to conquer they don't
have access to time travel anymore i
mean they kind of do but without really
having tony stark to essentially guide
them they don't really know how to chart
those waters right steve rogers is gone
you kind of have a new avengers team
everything's ragtag and it's in disarray
the entire chaotic nature of the marvel
cinematic universe
and the disorganization of the superhero
teams that's all part of king's plan
because if they're disorganized and
they're scattered and they're all over
the damn place they're not marshaling
their forces and they're not working to
defeat king this disorganization is
seemingly happening across the
multiverse the earth 838 universe with
the illuminati is the only reality we've
seen so far where you still have a
cohesive superhero team operating in the
what if stories and seemingly all of
those the superhero forces of those
worlds are either dead annihilated in
some conflict right some event where
thanos won or like ultron killed
everybody or they're just kind of ragtag
they're scattered and things are all
over the place it leaves the field open
for kane to operate without being
challenged in any capacity for him to be
completely and totally unobstructed
that's my thought here right now the
kicker to this is that it's one thing to
have a whole bunch of disorganized
avengers across the timeline it's
another to actually have things start
changing and to have various avengers
traveling around and basically
marshaling and recruiting other avengers
to a singular team which would come in
the form of the multiversal avengers
that we saw and jonathan hickman's
avengers and new avengers oh my god but
there's a giant gaping hole in this
theory there's a giant gaping hole here
and the answer and the whole is this if
kang sits at the end of time and if kang
is basically occupying the same role
that immortus held which is that
basically he knows exactly how things
are going to end then kang would simply
just stop that from happening he would
literally stop anybody from going out
there and basically marshalling the
avengers teams he would stop those teams
from coming into existence but that can
also be answered by the question that's
why kang is killing avengers he's wiping
them out he's wiping out anybody out
there that can present a credible
challenge to him and specifically
targeting different people in marvel
comics for example hank pym ant-man is
the scientist supreme of the marvel
comics universe meaning he's the
greatest scientific mind of that
particular universe there's no reason to
believe that when it comes to the marvel
cinematic universe that scott lang will
eventually reach that point we've kind
of see it play out to a little bit when
he's understanding science by studying
the quantum realm and things like that i
mean do i think he'll be a scientific
genius i don't know but it doesn't mean
that he won't be a significant person we
could also look at the idea of wanda
potentially being alive that what you
have are these nexus beings individual
beings that are out there that by
whatever manner and whatever means would
end up playing a crucial role in
defeating king and those are the various
avengers that kang is killing that in
that instance when he tells scott lang
like you're an avenger right like didn't
i kill you that he killed a nexus
version of a scott lang in an alternate
reality there's any number of
possibilities here but that's the
overall theme that like king's plan it's
already happening we simply just don't
know it yet the things that we've seen
or recently hadn't recognized it yet but
the things that we've seen take place
over the course of the mcu those things
are happening because king's allowing
them to because by allowing iron man to
die allowing captain america to go into
the past and basically you know grow old
and then come back to the present thor
losing his identity the incredible hulk
being pacified it was all instigated by
kang it was all initiated by him or
allowed to happen because it would
remove all of them from the landscape so
let me know what you guys think down
here right like let me know what you
guys think in the comment section i mean
obviously you guys are going to poke
holes in the theories you guys always do
but let me know
[Laughter]
how you guys feel about this but thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace